[Music]
what's up people michael here to talk
about a fellow bald digital media
personality who unlike yours truly has
inspired the exquisite wrath of
epidemiologists and 1970s folk singers
alike that's right mr joseph james rogan
now we talked about rogan's pension for
peddling vitamins with sky-high promises
in our video about men's wellness so be
sure to check that out but here's the
gist rogan was a stand-up comedian
turned sitcom star turned host to fear
factor turned ufc commentator who made
that rare pivot into global celebrity
when he started his podcast the joe
rogan experience in 2009. it was bought
by spotify in 2020 for a technically
speaking
ton of money and today it's the most
popular pod in the world rogan's devoted
fans regularly tune in to consume
episodes that often last longer than
your average rem cycle but lately
rogan's come under fire for spreading
misinformation about kovid interviewing
some pretty sus people and supplying
enough racial slurs for multiple
compilation videos in fact it's starting
to feel like the only person more
fervent than a joe rogan fan is a joe
rogan hater so what makes joe rogan such
a provocative cultural flashpoint why
does the seemingly normal specimen of a
man inspire equally aggressive amounts
of love and anger and ultimately what
does rogan's prominence say about our
society let's dig in and find out in
this wisecrack edition what's the deal
with joe rogan now let's be clear we've
posed a question with no easy answer joe
rogan's deal is innately hard to define
that's in large part because there
really isn't anyone else doing what he's
doing at least at his level of fame and
influence sure he asks people questions
under the pretext of gathering
information but he doesn't claim to be a
journalist he talks to experts but has
never himself claimed to be an expert on
anything except uh maybe porn oops yeah
i'm like i got it out of my system now i
can concentrate on my life my career and
if i meet somebody i won't be so needy
and he might perform stand-up but on the
show he doesn't function as a comedian
he's unabashedly in search of genuine
discourse about a range of topics his
listeners often say that they see
themselves reflected in rogan he paints
himself as an average dude who just so
happens to be able to hold his own in
conversation with everyone from
comedians to astrophysicists so
philosophy and quantum mechanics they
sort of they
they share some sort of a border
importantly rogan's crafted a platform
for himself that grants him complete
control over his public image and he
seems to use it to intentionally baffle
the mainstream media because rogan
rarely gives interviews the only way to
understand him is to actually listen to
his lengthy podcast this gives him a
heavily cultivated outsider status
that's even as he makes millions of
dollars off one of the biggest media
companies in the world and arguably
stands as one of the most influential
people in america but if rogan was just
innocuously interviewing tons of people
he probably wouldn't be instigating this
level of controversy though of course
some of his guest choices have been
questionable oh sweet baby jesus we are
live gavin mcinnes but where rogan gets
slipperier than a lubed up butter
sculpture of a dolphin isn't his actual
beliefs he has said if you say you
disagree with me i probably disagree
with me too i disagree with me all the
time and indeed his world view is
inherently impossible to define or pin
down his opinions are not even
internally consistent anytime someone
levies a critique about his views as
expressed in one episode there seems to
always be another episode where he says
the opposite it's a powerful tactic that
does not work in other forms of media
enterprise
typically ideological consistency is
demanded it'd be like if the new york
times editorial board refuted itself
every week and because any one of his
controversial opinions is personally
contradicted by him
he can get away with voicing just about
any viewpoint he wants
that means he can't really be held
accountable the way other public figures
actually striving for consistency might
be for example rogan might mock mask
wearing with comedian bill burr i just
love how wearing a mask became like this
like soft thing that you were doing like
being courteous being courteous what is
this
but just a few months earlier he hosted
epidemiologist michael osterholm who
issued grave warnings about the
importance of taking the virus seriously
well first of all you have to understand
the timing of it in the sense that it's
just beginning and so in terms of what
hurt pain suffering death has
happened so far is really just beginning
and then a year later he gave a platform
to cardiologist peter mccullough who
claimed that the pandemic was planned by
universities like johns hopkins it
seemed to be
completely organized and intentional in
order to create acceptance for and then
promote mass vaccination oh consistency
where art thou anyway by establishing
himself as an open-minded goofball who
just likes to chat with smart people
rogan creates a unique intellectual
liminal zone in which he and his
audience can just ask questions even if
those questions are being posed to and
by some controversial folks across the
political spectrum rogan belies
comparison with conservatives like ben
shapiro or alex jones liberals like the
pod save america guys or leftists like
streamer hassan [ __ ] the agenda being
relayed is always pretty explicit in
contrast rogan has cultivated a platform
of loyal followers who intrinsically
believe in and trust him despite not
fully knowing what his beliefs are
perhaps the closest thing we have today
to what rogan does is something like the
view where a group of women sit around
and chat about a broad range of topics
they lack expertise on but have strong
feelings about like rogan they'll bring
in experts to learn from to lend
credibility and to hopefully offer the
audience some intellectual value but
because there isn't really a the view
for men many fans see rogan as providing
a masculine coded space that doesn't
exist elsewhere furthermore rogan
doesn't talk down to his audience and
that's a big deal because a lot of rogan
fans see mainstream media as being
pretty judgy towards non-mainstream
opinions but rogan harbors no judgment
towards his guests or his audience hell
he's got no judgment for anyone come as
you are in rogan's universe everybody
with an opinion is cool from bernie
sanders to a proud boy the only real sin
is not listening to each other and
that's what makes rogan so compelling
his listeners don't feel like they're
being told what to think they see rogan
fostering open dialogue across the
ideological spectrum and then having
enough faith in his audience to draw
their own conclusions taken at face
value that sounds great if we buy the
curated image that rogan has crafted of
himself and his podcast it actually
sounds pretty benign now importantly
because of rogan's intellectual
flexibility and willingness to talk to
anyone many of his listeners describe
him as an outside disrupter speaking
truth to power and countering mainstream
narratives this characterization though
ignores an important reality these days
joe rogan is as mainstream as it gets
indeed each week his podcasts get more
listeners than any single evening of
programming on a major news network even
as he pitches himself as an outsider
it's hard to not call him mainstream
this apparent contradiction was
explained by the new york times podcast
the daily which posits that there are
really two mainstream medias at play
here there's what they call the
corporate legacy mainstream that is huge
newspapers like the new york times or a
television news network these
organizations are supposedly held to
certain journalistic standards and
practices like fact checking source
vetting and not spreading misinformation
in practice this doesn't always go
perfectly but the ideals still stand
reporters editors legal teams and fact
checkers all collaborate to ensure their
content is responsible and unimpeachable
they are machines with lots of moving
parts and a lot of money this is the
establishment mainstream and then
there's rogan's mainstream a sort of
wild west where the rules of journalism
no longer apply while a skilled
interviewer rogan's not beholden to
those same standards of research
sourcing fact checking and so on his
podcast is informal it allows a wide
range of viewpoints without concern for
whether or not those views are properly
backed up by standards like peer review
as a result he's seen as being
anti-establishment and allowing those
not typically given a platform to speak
so rogan's not journalism but he's also
not explicitly trying to entertain in
the usual sense of the word sure he'll
have funny comedians and actual
conspiracy theorists on his show but
he'll also invite highbrow intellectuals
in a world where the line between
entertainment and journalism has become
increasingly blurry rogan collapses that
dichotomy entirely and while his fans
may see themselves as pushing back
against the corporate legacy mainstream
they are very much a part of rogan's
mainstream complete with a huge voice
and a huge platform this is no
counterculture but his mainstream is
undoubtedly pushing back against
gatekeeping and the experts and
intellectuals that modern journalism
relies on are often considered to be
doing just that to understand rogan's
appeal as the self-defined common man of
the media we have to understand
anti-intellectualism as a force in
america now there's been a long-standing
tension in america between the so-called
elite intelligentsia and the average joe
while our earliest leaders were
undoubtedly the headiest of
intellectuals men of the mind were met
with suspicion as early as thomas
jefferson's presidential run in 1796 and
in the early 19th century as the ideals
of populist democracy came to the
forefront of the american consciousness
the goal was to eliminate status
differences in public life according to
a story in richard hofstadter the
leagues of common men wanted to get
along with as little leadership as
possible from the educated and property
class in a country where most people
didn't even have an elementary education
where could these common folks look for
guidance if not to learn its scholars
rather than say pushing to expand the
realm of higher education to make it
accessible to the everyman something
else happens as hofstadter explains as
popular democracy gained strength and
confidence it reinforced the widespread
belief in the superiority of inborn
intuitive folkish wisdom over the
cultivated over sophisticated and
self-interested knowledge of the
literati and the well to do
that is to say the ethos of 19th century
america was to trust your gut not a book
we see touches of this mindset and some
of rogan's logic driven but ultimately
disreputable pontificating today for
example rogan once said something about
coveted vaccines that might first strike
you as relatively intuitive but if
you're like 21 years old and you say to
me should i get vaccinated i go no yeah
are you healthy
are you a healthy person like look don't
do anything stupid but you should take
care of yourself you should if you're if
you're a healthy person and you're
exercising all the time and you're young
and you're eating well like i don't
think you need to worry about this of
course within the epidemiological
community there's near unanimous
agreement that young healthy people
absolutely should be vaccinated because
the issue is more complicated than
rogan's common sense
that speaks to an inconvenient reality
about our world the venn diagram of
intuition and fact does not always
overlap anyway rogan addressed the
backlash by essentially advocating
intellectual responsibility but back to
history anti-intellectualism in america
was really off to the races with the
rise of jacksonian democracy around 1822
andrew jackson's administration
distrusted expertise and intellectual
and basically kick-started their
expulsion from political life for
decades now as author tom nichols points
out in his book the death of expertise
societies tend to thrive when people
don't have to rely on their own
expertise in every single arena of life
back when everybody had to be able to
hunt their own food and build their own
homes and make their own clothes and
bind their own wounds workmanship was a
lot shoddier not having enough time to
devote to knowing one thing or a small
number of things made our ancestors
jacks of all trades and masters of none
but for a lot of american history this
kind of self-reliance by the uneducated
common man was extolled as virtuous at
the same time because most professions
back then required little to no formal
education intellectualism was seen more
as a luxury than as a necessity the
growing world of business also
emphasized intuition versus
over-intellectualizing again not unlike
joe rogan but as the world became
increasingly complicated via the
industrial revolution it also became
increasingly difficult to be
functionally self-reliant experts with
specific knowledge were brought back
into the fold of political life in the
progressive era at the end of the 19th
century where they would basically
maintain sway throughout the new deal
era back then their priorities pretty
much aligned with those of the aggrieved
common man who had seen their country
hijacked by the likes of gilded age
robber barons but what really changed
everything according to hofstadter was
the rise of anti-communist sentiment in
america see a fair amount of public
intellectuals had communist sympathies
and due to anxieties that climaxed
during the red scare of the 1950s these
experts in everything from social
sciences to chemistry to screenwriting
were systematically purged from public
life across the board intellectuals were
met with a suspicion and hostility that
as hofstadter noted in 1963 was still
alive and well but ironically at the
same time as hostility towards
intellectuals was resurging america
began needing experts more than ever
sofstatter explained of early 1960s
america society has grown greatly in
complexity and an involvement with the
rest of the world in most areas of life
formal training has become a
prerequisite to success at the same time
the complexity of modern life has
steadily whittled away the functions the
ordinary citizen can intelligently and
comprehendingly perform for himself this
only intensified as america became
increasingly oriented towards knowledge
work in the complicated post-industrial
revolution world we can't all know
everything so we rely on experts an
architect to design the building an
electrician to wire it a plumber to make
the toilet work etc in situations like
this we understand that someone who has
been trained and certified and worked at
it for years is probably the person you
want even if like me you thought you
could fix your toilet and then ended up
having to number two at a coffee shop
for a week but as nichols notes this
isn't the case when it comes to more
heady less hands-on work americans he
writes tend to really chafe at the idea
that we're not all equally as smart and
capable as the next guy especially if we
still suspect that guy might have
communist sympathies so even as american
resentment towards intellectuals grew we
became increasingly reliant on them in
every facet of life thus further
augmenting that resentment nichols
argues that this hostility has continued
into the present day and we think that's
part of why rogan is so appealing he's
not an expert and doesn't try to be he
embodies an overarching ethos that as
hofstadter puts it the plain sense of
the common man is an altogether adequate
substitute for if not actually much
superior to
formal knowledge and expertise and this
is an ethos that has dominated american
society for much of its history now
there's a real psychological reason why
trusting experts can feel disempowering
especially as we've entered the
knowledge era where hugely complex
endeavors like sequencing the human
genome or coding self-driving cars have
been accomplished it's easy to feel like
we know nothing and that's not a fun
feeling as nichols writes the fact of
the matter is that we cannot function
without admitting the limits of our
knowledge and trusting in the expertise
of others we sometimes resist this
conclusion because it undermines our
sense of independence and autonomy this
natural human reaction among individuals
is dangerous when it becomes a shared
characteristic among entire societies in
other words it's fair to hate being
wrong about stuff the problem is when
this becomes a larger societal mindset
because what happens if nobody's willing
to be wrong if every opinion holds equal
weight regardless of its grounding in
facts or reality when this becomes a
society's guiding ethos we run the risk
of dismantling the very foundations of
knowledge that enable progress as
nichols notes today the issue is not
indifference to established knowledge
it's the emergence of a positive
hostility to such knowledge it is a new
declaration of independence no longer do
we hold these truths to be self-evident
we hold all truths to be self-evident
even the ones that aren't true
and that's where we run into trouble
with joe rogan sure the guy consults
plenty of reputable experts but he also
consults people who have been ostracized
by the scientific community for
spreading misinformation and extolling
science that hasn't been replicated or
peer-reviewed he also regularly asks
people their opinion on topics on which
they are not experts and probably
haven't formed opinions with the same
rigor as someone with say a graduate
degree so what happens when this
potpourri of voices is heard on the same
platform the message becomes implicit
all of these truths are equally valid
when you have folks urging people to get
vaccines and some urging you not to the
collapse of reliable truths becomes
truly dangerous sure you might choose to
take the expert certified opinion that
vaccines save lives to heart or you
might vibe more with rogan's implicit
logic that vaccines are an unnecessary
risk for young people or you may favor
the doctor whose unprovable anti-vax
views leave him standing alone in the
medical community but when all opinions
are given equal weight choosing who to
believe becomes a trickier prospect and
this is actually made all the more
complicated by rogan's personal affect
he has an almost childlike sense of
credulity often acting as impressed
surprised or delighted by someone's
opinion and sure rogan might push back
on some of his most inflammatory guests
though he does give them plenty of time
to share their opinion but overall he's
more interested in hearing his guests
out than in engaging in rigorous debate
and this is the root of the problem to
explain we need to look to epistemology
a branch of philosophy concerned with
investigating knowledge and human
understanding or how we know what we
know specifically the subsection of that
branch called virtue epistemology virtue
epistemologists spent a lot of time
thinking about epistemological virtues
i.e intellectual virtues or qualities in
a person's character or disposition that
contribute to their ability to acquire
knowledge these include traits like
curiosity humility objectivity and
creativity epistemological vices as
scholar eric kramer explains are the
opposite character traits or thought
patterns that impede or prevent the
acquisition of knowledge these include
dogmatism intellectual dishonesty and
wishful thinking the most important
epistemological vice for our purposes is
gullibility or credulity though the term
epistemological vice is somewhat new the
concept goes way back in 1661
philosopher joseph glanville criticized
skepticism and credulity as equal and
opposite vices toward the obtaining of
knowledge of credulity he described the
human tendency to make precipitate i.e
hasty judgments when we choose to
receive all things via promiscuous
admission which coincidentally was
written about me in a bathroom stall in
college basically while the skeptic
might choose not to accept even the most
persuasive well-formed argument the
credulous person does the opposite
fragility implies a lack of discernment
incredulous folks tend to accept
knowledge from the latest person they
speak to in spite of qualification or
persuasiveness it's being promiscuous
with your brain which to be clear is
different than having an emotional
affair credulity like other
epistemological vices thus impedes the
careful acquisition of knowledge and
that's what we think joe rogan's show is
probably doing by presenting a broad
range of voices of varying degrees of
credibility without rigorous pushback or
a journalistic reliance on fact the show
establishes those views as essentially
equally valid and we'd argue that
rogan's much lauded open-mindedness
falls more in the camp of credulity
what's more the way he exhibits this
trait with nearly every guest encourages
the audience to similarly lack
discernment in a way joe rogan's success
in america makes a ton of sense he's
kind of the contemporary embodiment of
that old american populist tendency to
trust your gut when you hear something
that sounds right rather than listening
to the annoying expert who's been
studying the topic for years these days
it's become something of a cliche to say
that podcasting comedians like rogan are
the new philosophers but in rogan's case
epistemic credulity is precisely what
makes him not at all like say socrates
the first live-action podcaster socrates
built his philosophical wisdom on
self-examination and the acceptance of
one's own ignorance which meant that
when he had guest i.e athenian leaders
on his podcast iea street corner he
aimed to push them through a series of
questions to evaluate the truth of their
arguments unlike socrates rogan seems
mostly comfortable with letting everyone
share their opinions with some
exceptions rather than pushing his guest
and himself towards a deeper level of
self-examination so if you're seeking
philosophical wisdom
probably stick to youtube but what do
you guys think is joe rogan's show a
beacon of inquiry and wisdom or is it a
bastion of stoner anti-intellectualism
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons and be sure to check out
our patreon page if you have not before
cause we are about to unveil some very
cool new features pump up that subscribe
button like your rogan's beef fueled
biceps and don't forget to ring that
bell and as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
you